vous le savez on a parlé de pénurie te
fut au cours des derniers jours un peu
partout au pays et la popularité du
végétarisme de sa gagne du terrain
là il ya des appellations qu'on ne peut
pas utiliser ces mêmes interdits par
exemple saucisse de tofu ou steak
végétal interdit sylvain charlebois
professeur en tribu sion et politiques
agroalimentaires à lui verser à
dalhousie à halifax bonjour merci est
avec nous ce matin
oui bonjour j que c'est interdit mais
c'est interdit en fait en france et dans
certains états américains où on a
vraiment adopter certaines lois ou
effectivement en fait c'est surtout les
filières bovine et laitière qui contre
attaque
il ya une mouvance vers le véganisme le
végétarisme
il ya un engouement pour ces produits là
et on entend les termes comme boucherie
vegan mon le lait de soya
on entend parler depuis longtemps steak
au poivre vegan et ça crée un malaise
est de plus en plus on voit que le lober
de certains groupes en fait
f une influence librement et l'on voit
certains états américains à aller de
l'avant avec de nouvelles lois sur les
étiquetages pour bien éclaircir les
règles jeu en fait dresser en fait faire
la différence entre la protéine animale
et les protéines végétales donc cat et
américains en france on a déjà
réglementée ya environ six mois
oui ici ou si ça crée un malaise
pourquoi exactement à votre avis est-ce
que c'est une question de marché donc
des raisons économiques
vous savez actuellement bon tout ce qui
l'est via one ces secteurs là se sentent
attaqués
on a vu la semaine passée l'arrivée du
nouveau guide alimentaire qui en fait
croquer disait là la présence de la
protéine végétale dans nos dires tout
d'un coup alors chacun malaysie et puis
bah une façon de se défendre c'est
justement d'éclaircir les règles du jeu
sous verre on voit certains termes et
puis là on veut simplement dire bon
ciron vendre la viande il faut que
l'animal de danse simplement ou le lait
fauquet du lait le fromage vous avez
sûrement entendu parler du thème le
fromage
c'est là au jeu avec les mots et puis
justement on veut on veut éviter du sol
avez vous l'impression que au canada
aussi on va devoir légiférer en la
matière moi j'ai pas cher je voyage
beaucoup je rencontre beaucoup de gens à
travers le pays
je suis québécois d'origine je sais
qu'au québec une sensibilité au niveau
aux appellations contrôlées
je serais pas ce prix puisque la france
déjà a pris position là dessus il ya six
mois j'ai l'impression que c'est parce
en france bord influencé québec à court
terme parce que déjà je sens que que
qu'une vainqueur vague de contestation
au québec l'homme stipule et il ya des
représentations qui s'effectue et j'ai
l'impression que québec va vont être va
mener cette campagne au canada et pas
après ailleurs au canada
on risque de voir le secteur bovin en
alberta saskatchewan suivent le
leadership du québec à ce niveau l'homme
aux les pressions qu'ont on va voir
quelque chose qui va s'étendre sur
quelques années oui parce qu'on assiste
à tout un virage dans l'industrie
alimentaire est ce que vous avez une
idée vous des pertes économiques
encourus par les producteurs de boeuf ou
dépend par exemple dans le cas du boeuf
et du porc ils peuvent toujours
exportées dont sont moins affectées par
une demande domestique qui qui qui est
en transition dans l'est c'est différent
parce que dans l'oeil la gestion de
l'offre ont produit ce qu'on a besoin
alors si la demande domestique c'est
évident qu'on risque de perdre et fermer
ou de transforce en transformation
alimentaire et bourbon - d'emplois alors
les pertes économiques dans le secteur
du luxe surtout peuvent est réel ouais
voilà pourquoi on entend parler d'autant
est d'inquiétude depuis des mois
concernant la gestion de l'offre entre
autres c'est l'une des raisons c'est
bien charlebois merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin faisait au revoir